ils n'étaient pas nés là-bas ils avaient
cessé d'y passer ses week-ends et ses
vacances et pourtant il en était le
meilleur ambassadeur
je les aime 2
je classe d'ozil
avec la chanson le loir-et-cher en 1977
le chanteur rendait hommage à la sologne
de son enfance tout montage l'ambiance
qui règne les animaux la forêt tout ma
tâche c'est l'odeur tous l'odeur
indéfinissable with d'odeurs de terre
mouillée de mousse de marécages je sais
pas c'est difficile de dire simplement
je ressens quelque chose de qui me fait
toujours plaisir
michel delpech passé son temps à duisans
le village de son grand-père et à la
ferté saint cyr cette sologne
mystérieuse et reposante
il avait arpenté du matin au soir été
comme hiver
et cette terre de gibier l'ue avait déjà
inspiré en 1974 le chasseur une chanson
dans laquelle nombre de français
s'étaient retrouvés
soit
selon m
fait
le loir et cher
ce natif de la région parisienne le
portait en lui et l'a rendue populaire
auprès de millions de français
avec ce talent inimitable pour capter le
parfum des années 70
à
je garde de lui c'est quelqu'un qui a
accompagné toute ma vie de wight is
wight à son dernier album c'est
quelqu'un qui écrivaient les chansons
comme on parle je trouve qu'on est tous
un peu du loir et cher aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'hommage est dans la rue
bien sûr mais aussi sur la toile où
l'artiste avait fait des adeptes
je n'ai jamais je vais moi je passe le
dimanche dans le loir et cher
thür
un poisson